اهلا وسهلا بك سياده العميد بالبدايه معبر
باب السلامه منذ 2020 لاول مره تدخل منه
المساعدات الامميه ماذا يعني ذلك وما هو
حجم المساعدات التي دخلت حتى الان اهلا
وسهلا بكم في الحقيقه كما اسلفتم ان
المساعدات الامويه لم تدخل الا
اول البارحه ودخلت احد عشر شاحنه والبارحه
دخلت شاحنتين اي تاخروا كثيرا جدا جدا
للدخول وهذا معبر دولي من عام الخمسين
مفتوح معبر باب السلامه بالتالي والله نحن
تفاجانا من المجتمع لم نتفاجا اصلا مجتمع
الدولي من اول الثوره خيزل الثوره السوريه
وزلزال يا جماعه حالي انسانيه بعد اربع
خمسه ايام سته ايام من جثث تحت الانقاض
لحديات المساعدات الدوليه تدخل وعبر
موافقه المجرم هذا شيء لا يصدق ابدا ابدا
من المجتمع الدولي الحقيقي طيب ماذا يعني
الدخول المساعدات من معبر باب السلامه ما
هي اهميه معبر باب السلامه
معبر اساسي في المنطقه كما قلت لك معبر
دولي مفتوح من عامل 50 انا في هذا المعبر
منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات اخدم بهذا المعبر
سابقا
وله حيويه كبيره جدا يصل منطقه محافظه حلب
من هنا اربعين كيلو متر متوسط ضمن المنطقه
جميعها الزلزال قريب علينا من جنديرس
حوالي 30 كيلو متر المنطقه اللي تضررت
بالتالي يوجد لدينا كما تشاهد للمعبر
لدينا 30 الف لاجئ موجود لدينا هنا في
المعبر منذ سته سنوات ايضا من اللي نزحوا
جدا حاليا اجوا لعند اهاليهم واقاربون
فمعبر حيوي جدا جدا ومفتوح من اول الايام
وانا كنت اتفاجا من القناه وجميع القنوات
ان المعبر مغلق والطرق لا تصل اليه ابدا
لم يغلق المعبر واستنفر كل الكادر المعبر
وايضا الحكومه المؤقته انشات خليه ازمه
موجوده لدينا هنا في المعبر جميع الوزراء
موجودين لدينا وشكلوا خليط ازمه ومفتوح
لكن لم نتفاجئ لم يدخل احد ابدا يعني
المعبر من الجانب السوري جاهز لاستقبال
المساعدات ماذا عن الجانب التركي ما هي
المعلومات لديكم ايضا الجانب التركي
الجماعي فاتحين من اول نهار اصلا لم تدخل
اي مساعدات في اول يوم وثاني يوم وثالث
يوم الزلزال الا من الجانب التركي مشكورين
يوجد منظمه
ادخلت للان 43 قافله منظمه وقف الديانه
ادخلت اكثر من عشر قافلات الافات ادخلن
اكثر من 30 قافله اما المساعدات الامميه
لم يدخل الا باليوم الخامس من الاخوه في
كردستان العراق الحقيقه مشكورين دخل اكثر
من 25 قافله غذائيه وادوي البارحه دخل ست
سيارات اسعاف وكادر طبي الاخوه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مشكورين جدا دخلوا من
معبر الحمام 12 قافله واليوم ان شاء الله
ايضا معبر حمام تابع للحكومه السوريه
المؤقته في قافله قطريه من 14 شاحنه
مشكورين جدا وذهب رئيس الحكومه ورئيس
الائتلاف الاستقباله من اجل ادخال هذه
المساعدات طيب الى الى متى سيبقى معبر
باب يستقبل المساعدات الامميه يوم امس دخل
وفد اممي عبر معبر باب السلامه هل هناك
وعود بتكثيف المساعدات الانسانيه عبر هذا
المعبر وغيره من المعابر صحيح اخي البارحه
كما شاهدتم دخل نائب رئيس الشؤون الامميه
والتقى مع رئيس الحكومي السوري المؤقت
واتفقوا ان شاء الله حاليا فتحوا معبر
السلامي ومعبر راعي لمده ثلاثه اشهر
لادخال مساعدات الدوليه ووعده بادخال
مساعدات كبيره تليق في هذه المنطقه ان شاء
الله
شكرا الك سياده العميد طبعا كما ذكر ذكر
ضيفي سياده العميد قاسم القاسم مدير معبر
باب السلامه هناك وعود
اطلقت عبر الوفد الاممي الذي دخل يوم امس
عبر معبر باب السلامه وقال ان هناك سيكون
في الايام القادمه تكثيف للمساعدات
الامميه التي ستدخل الى الطرف السوري عبر
المعابر الحدوديه هناك معبرين معبر باب
السلامه ومعبر الراعي في ريف حلب الشمالي
سيبداان بدخول المساعدات الامميه لمده
ثلاثه اشهر وسنتابع معك هذه المساعدات
بالتاكيد شكرا لك الصحفي محمد الاشقر من
باب السلامه